You are now live with Layer Eight Culture,
Tech Thursday.
Welcome to another Tech Thursday.
It's right here.
Go on.
into it actually let's start off on last
week he's left off with um green foods
market from the website and i want to
show y'all what we've been working on
since then so you know
So.
Thank you.
So what we left off last week is
we did four different mock-ups.
I should lower my chat a little bit.
Check something.
All right,
so what we left off with Greenpeace Market
is we had all of their .
We had their existing website .
And your Facebook was pretty, I hear,
pretty up-to-date.
We referenced that.
We actually reported from mock-up images
of websites.
So what we did was,
it's one long organic tutorial.
We got premium botanical.
probably my least favorite.
But we had a right on my marketplace,
which is more store,
online store oriented.
I do like, after going into a build,
I actually build it out.
Because I built out,
actually not built out,
but going through the process of thinking
about it.
So I actually do like this layout.
And I go like this about it.
community editorial this is this report is
about the jazz um
to all that which is a rule.
Incorporate those issues into the model.
Same concept, same style.
Just incorporate both of the pictures.
Chop plants and herbs slowly and quickly.
And then we'll see.
Okay, so then after doing all that,
that's where we left off right here.
So,
what I think for me this market was,
I took those four pages,
went back into Copilot CLI, and had it,
or the AI,
actually analyze a board of three
mock-ups,
on what they want what we want to
do with business to find a recognition so
what i really like to do with the
um it's important to i'm a virtual person
so i wanted to do a presentation and
you can actually do that without having to
do a powerpoint but we decide to sell
to build you a html presentation it's a
lot it's very lightweight i think this is
like four kilobytes just super
send it as a file,
you can convert it to a PDF,
and you get no profile CLI as well.
It's actually preferable to PDF.
There's something about issues opening
HTML files, but .
So you can always convert it to a
PDF,
and you can also find databases to help
you.
But here's the cool thing.
So I'm fully dynamic,
presentation.
So I'm going to speak professionally.
So you have Greenfields Market, four page,
four homepage concepts, value,
one player recommendation.
And you can present this to a client
as it's like, this is your first step.
So going through,
talks about what we designed for,
talks about like the main book or concept
of Greenfields Market.
It's all we know.
which goes into kind of foundation.
I don't know why this, let me just,
oh, that's weird.
Oh, you know what?
I removed the image files.
That's all I'm gonna do.
I didn't remove the image files from the
concept.
Okay, so here's concept A.
This is the concept that you remember.
I really like this concept because it's
super easy, but at the same time,
the extra stuff,
as far as the plant-based care treatment,
the fruit trees, plants, and the herbs,
and the use of natural care.
Like, it was like fun,
and it wasn't anything that had to be
hidden.
It was right there for you.
And this is what,
so you can get any sort of bonds
and stuff.
So anyways,
close to all the four concepts,
that provides a recommendation.
even does the scoring based on the
different knock-ups.
So it shows you where, even for me,
the score tied in the story and emotion.
And of course, to me,
that's the one that I most score tied
in the strong story and emotion.
It's always been very distinctive.
And then having a warm,
And then, like, even with the one,
the first one,
it still scored low in e-commerce.
But then again, like,
the e-commerce wasn't the main focus of
the site.
They have a Squarespace that they'll
pretty much fix up.
So, like,
you just hit a shop and it will
show you some Squarespace.
So, Squarespace.
So, that wasn't a major selling point.
for the initial sign, so that's okay.
Everything else scored before the high.
So, strong recommendation,
and then the close second up is the
C, the power, the best sign.
Here.
So surprisingly, like,
C was a strong recommendation.
It was probably, like,
one of those things.
It was probably, like, for me, one,
and this one, and this one,
and this one, and two.
Yeah, two minus three.
Yeah.
So.
from there we went back to chat and
within chat we said hey so this is
inside moving to the screen that's a shot
of the mock-up that was in that
presentation and actually that was the
entire page let's change out of that and
then say hey which stack of skills and
repos would be best suited to create this
website let's go to NCI and I'm sure
you can find it gave me the stack
and recommended a lot of tools and
And then from there,
my prompt was pretty simple, like,
create this website, create some mockup,
reference the image, and say, you know,
use this for styling, use this UI,
use this.
I think that was all of it.
Yeah, I didn't use it in this episode.
I didn't.
So...
First section of the site,
this is focused on primary.
It's .
Here's the site.
It is not.
It is pretty much this.
I'm installing a website.
One thing that we want to see,
that I added,
was some context about content.
And it kind of gets into our topic
for tonight.
I have no idea.
I just wanted AI.
So,
I used one agent to build up the
website.
I then
It's kind of lacking as far as
copy of content.
It's just kind of repetitive,
kind of basic.
And of course,
it's understandable because we don't have
the definition of goal.
So if you have an existing website,
a ton of existing content, reference,
it would be easier to develop that text
font theme, but it just wasn't there.
It's actually a website content that we
can do an analysis for the target audience
for Greenpeace Market.
It's an exciting topic.
I literally did this with myself for a
while.
I was like, let's do this.
It's involved questions about the content.
should focus on comes like, all right,
well, we really want to build out,
we really want to be leveraged like a
in-store business.
We will get people to the actual store,
open it out of our quota,
and then we'll walk through a call number.
But then we also want some content to
establish people's market as an authority,
so gardening, when it comes to health,
when it comes to plant, herbs,
all that stuff.
We want to make sure that
provided some information and guidance.
So, the agent made his recommendations,
and then drafted it all out.
That basically gave,
that gave me a lot of flexibility to
go in there and create content based on
what we were able to do.
So now all this content was, you know,
Lori Pauline didn't have to go through the
pulpits and pull this out.
A lot of this was based on kind
of where they are in Florida,
what the food market represents,
and all the content.
So I think post-grad are new to that.
Everyone here in Platte Bay is based in
Florida,
so you'll see that in their story,
what they grow, what they follow,
how they grow in Florida, animals,
plant-based kitchen,
and answer plant questions from their
neighbors for over four years,
how they look around, or call ahead.
They know exactly what goes into their
story.
This market is interesting.
Questions about shelves, discovery,
and success.
Have a conversation about what they are
bringing.
The economy has changed a little quickly.
This market is interesting.
And then down here,
we have some down here.
It's, oh, sorry.
Yeah, what guides us?
The best way to know marketing is to
walk through the boards.
So like, literally, we have a full copy
wants the user to come,
inviting them to come into the store
called Saltus.
It's very pretentious.
so our story so give me a visit
gives the address hours i didn't need to
get there actually
So I'll take that.
It's out of the shop.
I'm going to talk to them.
You could do a form on the site.
It actually goes out to Google.
I'll just put that in the form.
very clean, very intentional, the box,
the colors.
So really fun part.
So beyond that section,
So now we want to make sure that
we're providing information
So our content manager agent actually
created three different guides.
This was intentionally done as a three.
Just go across these specific categories.
The plants, the herbs,
and then the pantry aspect.
If you go back to the home page,
those are the three main colors.
So those guides are lined up here.
So I'm going to go to
The cool thing is,
when Google goes ahead and searches,
it's seeing this information and saying,
oh, hey,
I've got something that's in authority in
some of our county on food treats.
They're developing information,
providing information out to some source.
And then it even has the cited sources
and references for this article.
Again,
it's still in the style of Greenpeace
Market.
Talks about mats for your yard, loquat,
mango.
Sandy soil.
Talks about being prepared for cold
nights.
And then you talk about herbs for a
week.
So basically, like, it's time, right?
Advice to sources, like, yeah,
this is so good.
And then you ask, like, I don't know,
quickly,
because we don't want to get into
services.
at this country so folks things you can
plant and run into your pantry so that's
the same so very clean side and i
also got to have a show this is
the volume quality guy this is like this
and maybe if you see it actually moves
actually appropriate and features here
a lot of people say like why do
you always website i think for me at
least um every business needs a website
maybe you're gonna be on a business like
anything you have like that's how you tell
your story like through but it's now i
just wanted to tell you something like
your website of course you can have a
youtube video or social media
all these things but like your website
it's important in foundation when you're
establishing a brand business it's
important to have it i mean not only
just website but then you know having the
domain name that you own it's super
important and um it's a great it's a
first impression you know
You see it's fully done.
There's thought behind it.
There's a little craftsmanship behind it.
It's very important.
It's your best for the head.
So we'll present this to all involved this
week.
So let's get into the main point of
discussion.
So we talked about this whole idea of
what age is like.
Actually, we're talking about props,
right?
And then getting into level two,
level three.
And that's where, like, workflows come in,
right?
Like, let's see.
Like, some things we did in the past.
A couple of them.
We talked about scheduling.
the workflows, or sorry, the prompts,
scheduling prompts.
Here's one that I would be in at
my tech groups.
Schedule,
and you try to continue this on certain
time based on the instructions I give it,
but you would
content on a daily basis.
So this is my daily template,
reading forward to it.
So I'm focused on AI,
I'm focused on apps.
I have a couple articles.
So that's like, that's it.
A prompt that's automated.
So that's automation.
You can call it an evidence-technificator.
Now,
when you have this idea of an
agent-to-worker or a group of agents or
sub-agents working for you, right?
It's important to understand the
organization structure.
I have a business background,
so I understand the organization
structure.
how organizations work online,
and kind of how the different types of
structure work.
So here's just like a little bit blog,
ten types of organization structure.
You don't have to do all ten.
You have your traditional hierarchical.
I'll go through this real quick.
Because I didn't know this article before.
I already know this like three of them.
So, hierarchical.
I can't.
So,
this is like your traditional
organization, right?
You got all the directors.
You have your executive board,
which is normally the CEO.
Actually no, you have board director, CEO,
then you normally have directors,
or you'll have like a CFO,
chief financial officer, CMO,
chief marketing officer, CTO,
chief technical officer,
a series of boards,
and then normally you have directors.
And these groups of people have
It's a functional structure.
So this slide function.
I like this one.
It's like.
So this one,
you'll have a head of IT,
and you have like a security manager,
network manager, office switch architect,
help desk, infrastructure support manager,
and you have the executive force, right?
So they're organized by function.
Then you have a horizontal with flat
organization.
This is where like,
The main person will just have a bunch
of director boards.
They will have layers of director boards.
Find divisions and some more divisions
that will help with education.
Real estate division,
a great example of this would be like
And they might be sectioned off by
regions.
So I feel like their strategy for South
America is different from the strategy for
Europe.
So they might have a South American
region, a European region.
Then you'll have basically copies of that
structure across the different regions.
I mean,
that might have multiple products that are
like key products.
I think we'll call it,
we're gonna create an example.
Who calls?
I'm gonna create an example.
It's a school.
In a lot of cases,
that means our product isn't just such a
massive company.
We have other companies that didn't work,
so.
Here we go.
Let's say you have some main products.
You have the main organization page.
You have general manager.
Anyways,
so the point of all that is I
want to say that it's important to
understand the structure.
I'm sitting up in here right now.
Because when you think of what you want
to do with AI,
you want to be able to
Let's see.
It's out of the drum.
So.
Watch.
Change.
So.
so i'm trying to place this video so
let's see if it's hot right okay let's
say i have all the different things i'm
doing like i'm doing
development and building stuff.
Searching for new ideas.
That's a lot of things that you're doing.
But guess what?
Like,
what do you need an agent to do
next year for your thing?
Like, starting one, two, three, four, six,
seven agents at once.
That's just you thinking about properties.
Probably tons of other things that
business owner, I'm told,
is still a startup.
What you guys did is that instead of
creating like all these different agents,
you gotta understand structure.
So let's say you go back to here.
This is probably the best one that I
chose what I'm thinking,
but it wouldn't be these specific roles.
Thanks.
So, let's say this is me.
Instead of having, like,
an individual agent that does one thing,
oh, there's one tool.
The function is actually making sense.
I also don't really have to call it
out.
So, it's what you need.
And then let's say, like,
This says security,
but think of it this way.
Let's say I want someone that does my
communications,
prioritizing tests for the day.
Oops.
Actually, any of this won't do, right?
Instead of you sending them and building
an agent that
sends emails,
but that student wants to know,
I want the chief of staff agent, okay?
My chief of staff agent is going to,
what do you call it, executive assistant,
whatever you want to call it.
But they have to understand.
And instead of just having that one
function,
it has a group of functions based on
what department this is, okay?
So that's one agent.
The next agent could be a project manager.
So your project manager agent is going to
take all your tasks and take the bigger
tasks, break it up, manage those tasks,
create a timeline,
keep you on track towards your goal.
Then you could have, let's say,
the technical
like have a board of directors or a
board of agents
function is.
And then what you do is,
so for them to actually run what's called
an autonomy sleep, right?
They're not really running autonomy sleep.
What you're doing is you're telling them,
hey, get the chief staff agent ready.
to get this agent instructions on,
this is called Chief of Staff.
And for Chief of Staff,
you gotta give this person time.
All right, so just say daily,
what would you say, an hour?
An hour is only probably,
if you want something to mean an hour,
So let's say twice a day.
That's a lot of .
So,
So you want the chief staff to do
something two times a day,
price the report,
then also you want to be able to
chat with the chief staff member.
So chat.
And you chat using WhatsApp, Teams,
You can text it, you know, use Telegram,
and you want to be able to chat
and reach out to your staff agent.
You can set up like a web UI.
You can chat with that person.
You can give that person a name.
You can give their personality if you
want.
But think of it as a person that
doesn't do just one thing,
but
has a certain skill set of things that
it does.
And then you also have your technical.
So your technical architect, developer,
tech advisor, CTO,
whatever you want to call that person,
right?
that person can analyze on a that person
can analyze on a weekly basis or monthly
basis once again you don't need a tech
advisor to send you stuff every single day
so a weekly can provide some type of
report
to you, make the recommendations,
provide those recommendations to you in
the form of changes that you have to
go through,
and then they actually are the ones that
go out in the form of exchanges.
Great example, right?
You have this person do an analysis on
security.
Again,
you don't have a just a security person
you have a technical person that's doing
security on your kind of assistant
self-providing you know report on how
secure your business system is right and
then you also do something where that that
tech agent
goes out and looks at the latest tools,
the latest technology.
That's a beautiful thing to be learning
from your business,
because that person understands your
business.
At the same time,
you sit and chat with this person, right?
You chat, give that person a name,
interact with them, make updates,
ask questions,
So I hope you get the concept of
like why this is so important.
This is something I'm building out in my
work life, corporate life,
in my personal life,
having all these different agents.
I have an attitude about ten,
ten different things.
Actually, that's in the future.
chief of staff, program manager,
project manager, technical architect.
So what's happening in a lot of
corporations is flattening out the
organization.
So instead of having all these different
layers of this person, that person,
this person, that person, this person,
it's like, okay, this general manager,
this CEO director has a company that
supports them.
Those people need to be able to do
a lot with the
And instead of going out and having to,
let's say,
have to go out and hire people to
manage, or hiring, like,
contracting a vendor,
I can build out a team of ten
virtual agents,
virtual people that I have to manage.
I have meetings with them.
They ask me questions like, hey,
I'm doing this.
What should I do?
And I'm like, hey, do this, do that.
Reference this.
So you have to keep asking questions like,
is this a social truth?
I'm interacting with these virtual agents
pretty heavily.
And it's definitely not only cost savings,
but it allows you to do so much
more.
It allows us to not have to be
experts in everything,
but we can still have depth.
I don't necessarily have to be a finance
guru.
to do my job,
but I can have an agent that's the
one that goes deep to understand the
financial impact of finances.
So it does bring more back on the
person that's running a business,
the person that's in corporate America,
to not just be good at one thing,
So you have to be able to speak
to and understand multiple things,
multiple principles and concepts in what
you do to be effective.
So a guide is definitely there to help
with that.
Again,
you have to be able to have a
structure, understand the language.
Language is so important.
I got a little words to say that
if I've been a guide
that English and Hebrew language,
it's the ultimate foreign language of the
future.
It's so important to understand language,
not only for ourselves,
but interacting with you guys.
Look at my bookshelf.
I wouldn't say it's a huge collection,
it's just a small collection.
So I put this here,
the black logic tree.
And that's the logic tree.
I think it was like, .
I think it's fine.
But, um, it goes into this dictionary,
of course,
but provides the words in terms of, like,
the law.
If I go into the dictionary and have,
like,
one word that might have three different
meanings, right?
And this, like, one word has, like,
it's down in the letter of the law
what it actually means.
Because sometimes I'll think of words like
that.
Why is that word used?
Like the word offer.
I have a friend.
I don't know what an offer is.
But then I offer you something.
But when you talk about offers in terms
of like sales and go to the market,
it's like the world behind me.
It's like something that you package up.
It's like products and services together.
to provide that to a customer to say,
hey, this is the offer for .
But then like when talking about,
talking to someone you might be like,
okay, so what's your,
so like people might say things like,
what's so, so make me an offer.
And then, like, it's not the same thing,
but what is the true definition of an
author?
And why do we use that term?
So I say all this to say that
AI doesn't always fully understand what
you're saying.
So it's important that you understand what
you're saying as far as the words that
you're using.
When we say leverage, like,
I use the word leverage a lot.
But that means, like,
don't use it directly, but, like,
use whatever you want to leverage to get
to this goal.
Use it however you can to get to
the main goal.
Leverage my access to this Gmail account.
I don't know.
Some of the things about as you direct
your AI, that's my challenge to you all.
When you're interacting with your AI,
you need to be mindful of what you're
doing.
Switch it up, use different thoughts.
Even if it comes to thoughts,
go to your different AI partners.
If you have great subscriptions,
I think that a lot when it comes
to like my low bicep,
when I'm going through with the text to
like, you know,
like instead of me going through something
like not to make music,
I'll just go gently and say, okay,
this is what I'm thinking,
you create the prompt.
And
So be intentional about your prompts.
Understand structure.
Understand organizational structure.
Especially when it comes to not
considering agents.
You can't really hire a team of agents.
Do this exercise with your bank.
Not this exercise.
You get the point.
Actually, you know what?
that's the right guide we put out next
week on how to build out your agent
organization leveraging organizational
structure in businesses that is the next
step I'll put it up on the agriculture.i
website of course
continue to reach out to us in the
community culture.
I can't say how it's working as far
as the concept of the pictures alone.
That's a lot of cool stuff we're working
on in the community culture within the
community, here at the Space Coast,
here in the Space Coast.
keep you guys posted on that.
But as always, it's been great.
I'll see you next Thursday.
Keep building.
Keep coding.
Thank you.
Out.
Peace out.